He's a smart one isn't he?
What are you gonna name it?
Do they look like just apes to you?
They're animals!
You saved our lives.
He was remarkable.
Apes Together Strong
You're him
You're Caeser
We've been searching for you for so long
I did not start this war
I fight only to protect apes
Human get sick
Ape get smart
Then human kill ape
But not me
I run
There are times when it is necessary to abandon
Our humanity
to save humanity...
They must pay
I'll finish this.
I offered you peace
I showed you mercy
You talk about mercy
No matter what you say,eventually you'd replace us
That's the law of nature
So what would you have done?
What did the humans promised you?
No matter what you do
You'll never be one of them
You are ape
We are the beginning
And the end!
Apes Together Strong
We are the beggining
And the end!
Apes Together Strong
I didn't come to save your apes
I came for you